hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments
father bimba babe Vivat wrap up what you
photoshop a eunuch own horn and have a
really big head Lowell love you mark
okay I guess
cool what if I told you potato people
are real
of course we're real with a potato
Empire and we have the highest yet yes
sir I don't know why you're talking to
yourself but okay cool we're people who
can you do a short dance please puns a
dance with puns hey ho what a milking
stools only have three legs because the
cow had the butter
Wow okay know another question I just
want to give you a huge running jump hug
and boob crush your face Oh God death by
boob so suddenly I'm so young what I'm
not that you I actually would like to
make a request that no one give me a
running jump tackle with their boobs or
not because I actually had a fan that
did a running tackle at me while I was
doing a signing and she nearly cracked
my back in half I had to lay down and
take about six Tylenol and recover very
slowly and slog through the rest of the
signing so please be gentle with the
marquee Moo this sentence is false well
actually you broke up your sentence with
multiple periods so that actually this
is four sentences and might I add this
is four incomplete sentences so you get
an F - go back home and think about what
you've done
don't rabble Sachs
what I don't know a joke for this one
huniepop is a porn yes and it's very fun
oh I shouldn't say that that's not what
I meant no take that back I mean it is
fun it's a fun game
I'm not saying porn fun oh god mark can
you say 7 chichi perfectly try it it's
funny
how did I do how it what did who did I
just insult and in what language I'm so
sorry
everybody mark you should try getting in
the gym business the world needs to see
more of your workout videos oh my
goodness well if I were to get in the
gym business and I have been working out
legitimately lately we've been rock
climbing a whole bunch of Matt Ryan and
I we've been going to the rock climbing
gym about every day now like pretty much
once a day and it's super fun because it
gets it's like an exercise that you get
to push yourself a little harder and I
always like the ambition of seeing
progress in since I've been going every
day and I've been care in my hands up I
I noticed now that I've been able to do
a lot of progress I'm able to climb some
walls with no legs and of course Tyler
is a big inspiration because he's trying
out for the American Ninja Warrior go
Tyler go with it good get picked I don't
know how it works but if anyone knows
anyone that works at American Ninja
Warrior get Tyler in there he's
submitted a video and it's good
we're now am I the only one that says
hello and bye-bye to mark with his intro
and outro I mean can I not well then
let's all do it together come on come on
little boys and girls let's all
participate three two one hello
god damn it Jeremy you got to
participate with everyone else you can't
just go Jeremy
hey Rachel with Sonia listen yeah you
don't look away right now
all right three two one bye-bye what did
you expect we were gonna do hello again
I mean come on pay attention Michael
Douglas Michael Douglas if you're
watching this you better pay attention
damn it mark I heard from my undisclosed
sources that you are a practitioner of
Taekwondo just as I am would you be kind
enough to attempt 10 tornado kicks in a
row without stopping or falling for our
amusement or and/or amazing it am i
doing it right am i doing it helping
leggo ha ha marklar if you the finebros
seananners in pewdiepie we're all in an
abandoned warehouse being chased by a
masked murderer with a power drill great
memories with no exits and no weapons at
all what would you guys do to escape
death well that's five people versus one
we just tackle the son of a [ __ ] get
him in a chokehold and drill his nuts
off what's the big problem here it's
five people versus one masked murderer
he's not gonna win so mark when was the
very first time you noticed how much
your fans care for you I still remember
when you had 1000 subs well oddly enough
I've told this story before but it's
about when I had 2,000 subscribers and I
first went to comic-con comic-con in San
Diego which I've been going to every
year and I really like going because the
first time I went I only had like 2000
subscribers but five people were for
four or five people I can't quite
remember I think five people came up to
me and recognized me and that was
amazing just like the statistical
weirdness of that happening
was amazing to me and I was so honored
that people actually came up and told me
that they really enjoyed the videos that
I made and that kind of that kind of was
like a paradigm shift in my channel
where I realized that I had more of a
responsibility for what I was doing you
can actually see the video I'll link it
in the description way long ago right
after I came back from San Diego
comic-con you can see baby mark so like
uncomfortable in front of a camera
because that was before I even did a
webcam so I'd never really shown myself
all that much but you can see it there
it's it's really a lot of fun I had a
great time in San Diego and you know
from then on I've really tried to make
this channel about making videos that I
want to make and entertaining you guys
for the sake of just having a fun time
and also doing good in the world because
you know this is very important what I
do here is very important and I hope you
guys learn from it not that I'm trying
to teach you a lesson but learn from it
that even when you're having fun you can
do good like you can do good everywhere
you go and it's very important so that's
probably one of the first time I
realized that the fans cared for me and
I had to care back markable are you have
helped me so much whenever something bad
has happened in my life bad grades
depression anxiety etc I just go to your
channel thanks and thank you for
watching you know a lot of people say
that to me that my channel helps them
through dark times and I'm honored I
don't want to put that down in any way
I'm honored that you guys turned to my
videos if you're having a bad day but I
also want to say you know to put it out
there not that it needs to be said
really but my videos aren't a magical
cure for real you know depression or
anxiety and like things like that and I
know that it's like a coping mechanism
for a lot of people and again I don't
want to like diminish the value of that
to those that are going through that but
also I hope that you're not solely
relying on my videos to get you through
these tough times because me personally
I make videos because I want to make
videos and I want to entertain people
and I'm so happy that my videos are an
outlet for people but if you're really
suffering through these horrible
struggles and I know a lot of people out
there are and trust me my heart goes out
to you guys but
if you're really going through these
tough times please like from me from the
bottom of my heart reach out and find
help like real help if you're going
through I've heard people that have
attempted suicide say that my videos
have helped them you know I've heard the
people that are in severe depression
help them please also find other help
because the most important thing you
could do is not keep it buried
underneath because that's where people
can't see it and if you're if you're
thinking you can just get through this
by yourself that's fine but it never
hurts to reach out and try to get help
from others so please make the attempt
to go out and get help if you need it if
you don't that's fine then I'm just
lecturing you for no reason but you know
just from me to you please don't just
rely on my videos but also go out get
some help talk to people if that's
really so thank you and I'm glad that my
fingers red mark you smell okay so
that's it for reading your comments I
promise that it's gonna start back up
every Monday the reason that I wasn't
able to do it over winter break is
because when I went back home my
microphone wasn't there so I had to
special-order a microphone because this
one that I use isn't made anymore so I
had to go get another microphone and
then when I got back it was already
after Monday and then when I got back
here we were doing the intensive improv
classes blah blah blah lots of excuses
but we're back on so thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want your
comment read in the next video write it
down in the comment section below
and trust me I read through a lot of
comments to get to the good ones not
saying they're all bad but there are
some bad ones out there so I'll be
reading so let me know what you think if
you have a special message to give me
write down there in the comments below
thanks getting everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye Michael